♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ENDING TONIGHT ON A
POIGNANT NOTE, THE END OF AN
ERA.
THREE WEEKS AGO THE STRUGGLING
AND FLEDGLING STATE OF CHAZ
SECEDED FROM DOWNTOWN SEATTLE,
FROM THE U.S. ITSELF.
A WEEK AFTER INTERNAL REVOLUTION
BECAME TRAPPED BUT THE NEW NAME
DIDN’T STOP THE TURMOIL.
AFTER A SERIES OF KILLINGS THE
WORLD’S YOUNGEST COUNTRY ALSO
HAD THE WORLD’S HIGHEST PER
CAPITA MURDER RATE, SENSING
WEAKNESS, ITS ENEMIES POUNCE.
SEATTLE MAYOR JENNY DURKAN
PRAISED CHOP WEEKS AGO SENT AND
POLICE TO RE-ANNEX THE COUNTRY
BACK TO THE U.S.
NOW COMES THE DIFFICULT TASK OF
REINTEGRATING ITS CITIZENS INTO
AMERICAN LIFE.
JASON RANCE HAS BEEN TRACKING
JAZZ AND CHOP FOR US.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THIS IS KIND OF A POWERFUL
MOMENT TO SEE THE FLEDGLING
NATION DISAPPEAR.
>> IT IS AND I HATE TO BREAK IT
TO YOU.
WE WERE NOT GREETED AS
LIBERATORS TODAY.
IT’S BIZARRE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO DO WITH THESE
FOLKS FROM CHOP BECAUSE ARE THEY
REFUGEES?
WE KICKED THEM OUT OF THEIR
SOVEREIGN LAND WITH OVERWHELMING
FORCE VIA BICYCLE COPS.
THEY DID PUT UP A LITTLE BIT OF
A FIGHT WITH THEIR FORTIFIED
BORDERS OF OLD COACHES WHICH BY
THE WAY, NOT WHAT THEY USED TO
BE BECAUSE THOSE BIKE COPS GOT
THROUGH THEM VERY, VERY QUICKLY.
THEY MUST HAVE BEEN IKEA.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
EXACTLY DO WE DO WITH THESE
FOLKS?
A WHOLE BUNCH OF TWENTYSOMETHING
IMBECILE PROGRESSIVE WHITE
PRIVILEGE DUDES WHO THINK THEY
BASICALLY DON’T HAVE TO WORK FOR
A LIVING.
THEY CAN JUST TURN TO SOCIALISM
AND EVERYTHING WILL BE HANDED TO
THEM.
DO WE REALLY EVEN WANT THEM IN
SEATTLE?
I THINK WE SHOULD GIVE THEM
DEPORTMENT.
>> Tucker: HUNGER HELPS
REEDUCATE PEOPLE.
NO ONE EVER DOES THAT IN OUR
COUNTRY.
I’M GLAD TO SEE US WIN A WAR
DEFINITIVELY FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN A LONG TIME.
WHERE ARE THESE REFUGEES GOING
TO GO?
ARE THEY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
STEW IN THEIR OWN FILTH ON THE
STREETS OF SEATTLE OR MOVE TO
PORTLAND?
>> THEY ARE KIND OF LOOKING FOR
ANOTHER HOME.
THERE’S RUMORS THEY ARE GOING TO
TRY TO TAKE UP SOME NEW SPACE
OUTSIDE OF THE WEST PRECINCT, SO
THEY ARE GOING FROM THE EAST
POLICE PRECINCT TO THE WEST
POLICE PRECINCT.
WE DON’T KNOW EXACTLY WHO’S
GOING TO BE THE LEADERSHIP THIS
TIME.
OBVIOUSLY, LIKE A PHOENIX RISING
THROUGH THE FLAMES OF A DUMPSTER
FIRE, CAME UP TO BE A BIG LEADER
AND HE’S KIND OF DISAPPEARED.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO IS GOING TO
TAKE THE MANTLE AND LEAD THESE
LOST SOULS TO THEIR NEXT
HOMELAND.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT ARE THE
CHANCES WERE AS SIMONE GOES BACK
TO HIS REAL JOB WHICH WAS
RENTING HIS APARTMENT ON AIRBNB?
>> HIS APARTMENTS ON AIRBNB WAY
BETTER THAN LIVING IN A TENT IN
FRONT OF A POLICE STATION OR
NEXT TO A PARK.
HE MAY BE SHE GO BACK TO THAT
AND PURSUE HIS RAP CAREER.
I AM CURIOUS.
IS HE LIVING ON THE STREETS?
A CHOP LEADER.
I WANT TO THE LYRICS.
I WANT TO SEE THE SOUL IN HIS
STORY.
HE HAS A STORY TO TELL AND I’M
HERE TO LISTEN.
SPEAK TO THE FIRST WORLD LEADER